rap battle this week oh he's back my
favorite parts they alert so - last time
we did it we had we huh what's that and
look I will tell you this dude I your
innate it next to Paul wall at a urinal
once [ __ ] yeah
and he was cool and he shook my hand
right after hand a hand and he knows
your hand was touching that day my own
dick goes in the urinal yeah then you
shook his hand with that day and he
shook hit my hand what a man what a man
you think he's wearing a [ __ ] one
mighty good show deals dick hand I'm
scared of getting [ __ ] paulie good 19
dude Cova control bro who has it who you
guys have it yet nope yet when you get
tested
y'all got tested no we didn't get tested
I want to get tested go to my buddy's
house and get tested today he has test
him so how much it cost though so mine
was $200 was it really what is this Nick
I'm just gonna hope I don't have it for
200 just play your odds it's a smart
move this rap battle so little brows
ended up winning we had a really close
fifty-fifty vote that was only separated
by 35 with wiser hip-hop and big gracias
and little de nada
those are both great but little brows
just dominated again we get so many
submissions now I have to that like
they're not as highly produced but
they're good and we should watch them
and they're quicker and then actual
contenders the contenders are [ __ ]
sweet let's put him in here comes young
white guy maybe have the same bloated
face apparently he's on the same
medication ah Mon bro don't be one of
the people that's blame and they're
freakin bloated face um thyroid medicine
thyroid medicine doesn't have frosting
on
let's go from a guy who cancellous
Bradish okay said his brain hurt brain
was leaking out of my ear that make
sense I woke up on warning and a couple
ideas I had where all my fellow I'm like
this ain't good I gotta cancel the show
see but I gotta shut it down dude I
could how far it takes to get there in
the traffic I do I've been there dude I
did it with you three times that's right
yep
what do you got a years ago Chappelle
weren't you saying here's the Instagram
yeah he's alive yeah as he thriving I
didn't look at him no it's like random
[ __ ] throwing one in the jaw right there
warming that jaw I'm a big dog this is
him yep there is Marshall Pope he had a
real Marshall Pope right there her
followers gang [ __ ] he's got a lot of
followers 300 I said he actually
returned this was all happened no pun
intended years ago he returned to the
news and he actually did freestyle if we
want to hear it yeah hell yeah
he redeemed himself slammer
booyah most [ __ ] up wrapping the right
self publishing books you're visible
shutters got the whole world [ __ ] Who am
I
damn Derrick Thomas car app away
here's one son three boss what the
struggles are love cuz love is hard well
I wouldn't be able to do with that the
love from God you're great don't be you
looks like Derrick Thomas rest in peace
yeah too many kisses Thomas a lot of
love Alabama's finest years ago years
ago oh I don't know brother three years
ago bring up Marshall Faulk gains weight
you think he looks like a thick Marshall
Faulk E yeah I don't know if there is
even a picture here marks or fault fat
yeah get that blue shirt not fun and
putting that blue here that blue t-shirt
no no no no no no [ __ ] go back yeah
right there no no blue shirt
thank you sir years ago bro use that'll
be good everybody getting fake when they
get older huh oh he does look like him
clothes I think it looks more like dirt
Thomas though I don't know bro that's
close overall I think it's really a mix
it's like Derrick Thomas and Marshall
Faulk had a baby he came out thick yeah
he came up they can uncertain hey you
almost got a mental he just years ago
yeah he weighs like no don't do it
we need Nick to redeem himself with that
Iggy song yeah one day Nick Chappell
dropped those [ __ ] flow forth it was
Paul Wall wasn't my flow but you
remember is he's not his flow yeah white
rappers are killing it over here yeah
except this one this was this came from
Jared who's actually a girl
and she wrote in her email not white I
don't have a penis and I've never
wrapped or made a beat but I have got a
white guy's name so put me in coach
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I know if I do it over that rock beat
that EDM that's fine yes you want a
tricky beat is a good effort first
female rapper what do you think at
female to female female the female love
her
okay she's not gonna be [ __ ] brows
though this is her first time Brendan
and no one put a kid on a tricycle and
think he's gonna be damn you know she's
a baby this is King even sings she's in
the big leagues
huh this is the big leagues not yeah
you're right trying to be brows but
bring the heat yeah it was a good effort
appreciate the effort is it good lady
she was great she was great they've just
become total that's great
this will lie to the lady also alright
what do you want man we have to give a
room to grow we have to be supportive
you know I'm supportive that's why I
said she's great it was a great effort
for her first time that's what I think
okay now she's gonna beat little brows
[ __ ] no
so yeah yeah so good luck for the first
black female that's true dude for Jackie
Robinson Kingdom she's Bubba Sparxxx
she's Rosa Sparky
what do you got Matt dude you know who
turned into throws up parks was [ __ ]
Cam Newton do but when he started
dressing like uh he started dressing
like a woman from the 1930s my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and his play went down you got his play
went down got crazy there's nobody's
giving him a deal right now
are they well some was gonna pick up
he's been so injured though yeah that's
true huh hell of a player though MVP MVP
in 2015 MVP you couldn't have an dude 25
he's a [ __ ] following man you know
what's crazy - he got kicked off the
Florida team when they had Tebow that in
Hernandez they had all those ballers he
got kicked off the team for stealing a
laptop no way hmm I do not steal a
laptop in college that's what I want to
know who wasn't stealing what else you
got like a real contender we got to
they're really good
[Music]
gang up in this [ __ ] wow that was fun
that's fun yeah it's hard to hear this
it's hard to hear a lot of what he's
saying why is that I don't know is he
loud enough in there oh no I think he's
just the way he sent it in or something
yeah it's just they're not all the best
produced like producers I mean yeah
they're just not the Nexus Raj and he's
not producing that thing but I mean for
doing himself like that was pretty it
was a huge video and yeah it was good my
like the bird I go yeah that was real
that was real quality put it he added in
a lot of photos and stuff man he did a
really good job man it was fun yeah
what's funny this one is also incredibly
fun this is from this is called tiger
sting by buck Jeffrey and little streaks
Oh buck Jeffrey a little Street both
Jeffrey and little streaks are played by
evan Davis that your as your [ __ ]
underwear company
not in a financially recovers book
Jeffrey don't ban will Chunkin Beach
horchata boy he never had this sharpest
deal here big butt club every all the
paint go hard like DeRose i'ma [ __ ] DJ
Paul zeros money the banks I don't quit
all go hard like the phone in the paint
touching on bust down masturbate back my
holes v king of the end zone shirts they
tucked in all day I went back scratch
margarine high socks no he's okay yeah
we've gone too far
yeah I feel like yeah white rappers get
weird on us dude that [ __ ] went [ __ ]
deep to be [ __ ] little brows I think
we gotta open up to all ethnicities I
don't know why boys get real weird
little brows speaking I've actually sent
in an updated version oh one new
positivity I hit it son Diddy mm-hmm Wow
spice it up premiering here and has
never been seen before
yeah I [ __ ] love this dude dude he's a
great block
how does like the Inkster okay last one
and then I am done they got me beating
on my chest fee fie foe fum they
sleeping on me like the slept Kingdom I
was waiting on a banger but I didn't
hear one except lazy girl sound an
outdated a bunch of guys on the couch
saying Flo new faces
don't say my [ __ ] is wack cuz you sound
crazy I got the beat doin flips like
Chappelle lazy woo cold but at the same
time I drop the heaters you boys sound
like wall-e from Leave It to Beaver gee
willikers man I wouldn't like me either
they trying to pick apart ground like a
parrot wheeze I'm the [ __ ] zone now
why'd you get me started trying to beat
me they don't have to try a little bit
harder here in the martyr when I'm in
the park a lot better like harder forest
between songs if I really wanna roast a
wall I could
but I would read between this to a cop
yeah yeah I can't see the haters from
the top
speaking kind of cringy y'all should
stop I just felt the competition drop
but I would read it through this tool
popping kind of cringy y'all should stop
I just taught the competition he is like
Brendan's hair on Theo horses in the
back shoutout to the Paiste bros Derek
sent away for way too many episodes find
out if his girl is okay and then let us
know don't shop with Kat all wrong so
many dogs coming off too strong chance
take it and really last that long just
bought a bunch of alcohol and then went
home y'all need a tiger King type a
throne that I can sit on so where's my
crown let me keep that king of sting low
growl King I can't see the haters from
the toss okay
these girls and their crazy y'all should
stop it why
[Music]
the competition alright beaker Libra
professional and hence so music he got
the neighborhood to be in his video at t
fern three gay yeah that's a pro son
buzz pro game son is that [ __ ] God
sham God is that it's Delonte West yeah
I found on the street oh man
little browse man there's so hard in the
paint
yeah a real pro Wow he said that's his
last one huh I don't think anybody's
ever going to beat him so I don't know
what we do I think we open up to all
ethnicities do we change the job I was
gonna say overall talent show or singing
get some instruments yeah what do we
change the middle up in this [ __ ] you
can rap sing whatever you want no one's
gonna beat little browse it's not having
which I think you never American my
dolls just give me cramps some of his
[ __ ] bull
[Music]
nothing
[Music]